hey dr. Berg here in this short video
we're going to talk about this subject
called cortisol and how to turn off
course all the first thing to know is
that cortisol is made from the outside
of the adrenal gland this is the adrenal
gland you have two of them on top of the
kidney they look like this so the
outside of this is all gland tissue and
cortisol is made by the outer part of
that gland the inside of the gland is
all nerve tissue
it makes neurotransmitters or
hormone-like substances that are hormone
like because they travel
communication-wise through the nervous
system where hormones travels through
the blood does the differentiation so
cortisol is made by the outside and the
inside would be all the adrenaline okay
so adrenaline is a stress hormone -
right cortisol is a stress hormone so
the thing is like a lot of people are
stressed out and they seem to not be
able to get rid of stress they can't
seem to turn off cortisol and that's
primarily because the the adrenal gland
only has an on switch see cortisol is a
hormone that reacts to stress and adapts
the body to stress dates okay and the
same thing with adrenaline it reacts to
stress and it adapts the body distressed
states so if you're oh if you've been
chased by a tiger for example you're
going to have the heart rate go up
you're going to have the blood flow to
your muscles you're going to have a very
awake brain and excessively you know
aware and then you're going to have a
higher blood pressure you're going to
have more adrenaline you're going to all
these different things but you're not
going to have as much digestion or
reproduction so it's going to turn those
things off but what happens over time
and a lot of people don't know this is
that when they experience stress over
their life they think when they go
through it
then the stress just goes away now all
stress is accumulative
I have a machine
measures accumulating stress and you can
see in a body the huge relationship
between the quantity of stress and then
in present time their body is stuck on
and will not turn off because the
adrenal only has an on switch it doesn't
have an off switch okay so all stress
accumulates and it's also interesting to
note that and I'm going to just tell you
it's probably a hundred percents might
be 99 percent of time but nearly a
hundred percent of time you take
autoimmune cases like rheumatoid and MS
and and lupus and all these different
autoimmune diseases it always happens
after a stress event primarily a loss or
some threat of loss or divorce or
whatever why is that because a loss is a
severe stress to the adrenal it shocks
the body even more than a physical
stress and the bird person can be stuck
in it for years as far as the physical
body gets stuck in it and then you're
over here but your body is still
reacting down there and then they turns
on this autoimmune thing so that's
interesting so we have this thing where
we have the adrenals that get stuck on
over time because if accumulated stress
it could be measured objectively you can
feel it subjectively just on how well
you tolerate stress and how you do a
stress if you can't tolerate stress and
things get to you easily irritate you
easily then we know the adrenal glands
are on edge now there's a term for this
called flight or fight mode so when
you're flutter fight you're in this mode
where you're constantly either fighting
or running away something it's like it's
a stress State so the flight of flight
can be measured as well and I can
measure that on a test and you can see
how much flight or flight the person's
in versus if it's normal or they're
stuck in flight or fight and a lot of
people are stuck in this water fight
from pass stresses okay and if these
stresses could be you know change of
hormones menopause it could be physical
stress mental stress could be any type
of stress at all so so that's really
what's happening is that we have this
hormone that's too high
this hormone is too high because of the
old stressed that you don't see because
it's stuck in the past so the do all
these tests and they can't find them
because it's not showing up at a blood
test it's not showing up on other tests
but it might be at blood pressure pulse
rate but you have to use a very
sensitive test to pick this up and I use
a test that measures this part of the
Drina it's called the autonomic nervous
system this is all sympathetic nerve
fibers so we can measure that on a test
it's called heart rate variability don't
worry about the name but it's just
realized there is a test that can
measure that and when I look at people I
look at two things one is how much
stress that they have in their body and
number two how much health or recovery
Reserve do they have as well because it
measures both both parts and I find that
it's a relationship and when someone's
usually in stress for long periods of
time they lose their health reserve
their recovery their their reserve to
back onto because you know if you lose
your recovery then a little bit of
stress really can affect you badly but
if you have good recovery and your
stress doesn't bother you as much
because you have this buffer to fall
back on so the question is what do we do
to turn this off okay and now one one of
the things that I found it's very
difficult to do this with pills and
things like that what I found you have
to do is you have to manually turn the
adrenal glands off now what do you mean
manually like adrenals are stuck way
into the body
well there's techniques that basically
work on other parts of this nervous
system okay it's called the sympathetic
nervous system and there is other parts
of the nervous system that control the
off switch and that's called the para
sympathetics so that's another word
parasympathetics means the part of the
nervous system that turns things off
because it controls rest and digestion
so inevitably someone that's stress
usually his problems with resting and
digestion so on
if you look at the whole body and find
out where these things are located you
can do techniques acupressure without
needles or massage on these locations of
where these things are located in the
body and create an incredible relaxation
effect that actually helps this part of
the nervous system so you're really
working not on the gland per se but
you're working on the nervous system
you're increasing the flow of this
electrical wire that's connected to the
brain that won't turn off it's like a
switch so I what I did is I listed a
series of videos below
in the link that you can click on to see
some of the techniques there's a lot of
them but I'm just going to show you a
couple that you can apply on your
nervous system to help turn off this
cycle okay so I want to just give you a
taste of this below but there's a lot
more we're going to talk about in future
videos but I want to just explain some
of the basics on what cortisol is and
how it affects adrenals and what's
really happening for people that are
struck and stuck in stress states so I
hope this helped and I will see you in
the next video